season three hours we're in season three
of Castlevania Wow all right Castlevania
is happening I'm pumped I hope it gets
past season one person castlevania
season three is the third season of the
Netflix Castlevania animated series well
you know what
spoilers spoiler alert for season three
and a little bit of season two I've just
found that when I'm talking about a
season of television is just easier to
be able to go anywhere talking about it
for season three oh yeah we're in a
different spot now than I thought we
would be if Castlevania ever got past
days and three if you like a season one
after what is one of the most
rewatchable pilot episodes ever by the
end of season one it's like alright the
band's gotten together let's go after
Dracula I mean all except Grant's
where's grants no love for grant grant
was useful more useful in the Famicom
version where you can throw knives when
he punches still useful you can climb on
walls where's grant any I was like
alright it's gonna be like Castlevania
they're questing and they're going to
towns and they're fighting monsters are
gonna quest all the way to drag you
those doorstep the end of season 2
Castlevania like I said spoilers
Dracula's dead witch Dracula dies that's
what he does and then someone brings it
back whether it's the dark priest shaft
a Dracula always gets brought back and
eat he's not not yet so a show that
started out as basically Castlevania 3
and the heroes or questing they're gonna
take on Dracula has ended up being a
much more character-driven story than I
thought it was going to be I see what
they're doing I think they're trying to
fill a void a void that definitely needs
to be filled if Castlevania the video
game adaptation the animated series on
Netflix is the one to do it I'll be very
impressed and I will say I'm invested
with the new characters anyway like
first and foremost Isaac Isaac most
invested with him I'm like yes Isaac you
create those monsters create those
demons go get your revenge revenge on
someone who's just you're just trying to
be good well be good
he was helping wipe out the human race
but is that really so bad a constant
that Castlevania does have to say is
humans are douchebags but no one's
arguing that that's why we're dog people
or cat people people person that's so
90s but also I was invested in Hector
he's now captive he's being kicked down
which you're like is he being played by
Carmela's sister I can't think of a name
rule 34 colorful I'm gonna look up her
name but the show's been out for a
weekend if it does
exist of her already I'm surprised
Lenore that's her name so you don't know
if Hector is being played or not then
again did we not clearly the entire time
I'm like don't fall for it dude to give
Wow urs I mean I like his character but
he's pretty trusting this attractive
powerful vampire woman who's on this
council of vampires who could have any
vampire dick she wanted now she she
clearly wants yours human guy yeah she's
probably playing you or you're right
maybe she likes she likes her men
squishy and human and clearly hit rock
bottom I'm speaking of rule 34 that
Alucard Zayn you know the Z the writers
of this show spent way too much time on
the internet looking up Alucard fan art
because it looks a lot like that so I
like the new characters that weren't
actually in season 1 all right I'll say
I like Sipho a lot actually I thought I
just liked her as a character
she's like adorable yet cool is got a
magic I like psycho never liked playing
her in the game she's way too slow but
her magic was business I like Trevor and
Sipho but their quest Osler what's going
on with the town of maybe Dracula he'll
come back no there's a loo card Alucard
is the classic case of never meet your
heroes there's what they say right never
meet your heroes all the cards just
moping around his really big house so
sad which totally get that he's sad
because he didn't kill his father he
killed his father the only two friends
he actually had left he didn't go with
them to now we're like aw Alec Ari's the
fan favorite best character in
Castlevania oh he's a really mopey
grumpy broken person just moping around
just really big house he's actually
quite sad Brennan a couple people come
to him and are like hey can we can you
train us and leads to more rule 34 and
them dying because humans are dicks but
even then you get the feeling he's
dragging his feet because he's like I
just want company I'm lonely lonely
elder card is the old lady in the
neighborhood who gives hour-long piano
lessons and at no extra charge extends
that hour-long piano lesson to an hour
and a half and then after the hour and a
half long piano lesson begs you to stay
and watch jeopardy with her because it's
been really lonely around here ever
since Earl left 20 years ago lonely out
of the card is a mood but I get it I get
where they're going still of the three
seasons it's probably my least favorite
but time can totally validate the
decisions they made here it's all about
how al they stick the landing and I hope
they do because I legitimately
they might be aiming to fill the void
that we've needed filled for a few years
now which is the Game of Thrones voice
yeah I say a few years now not one
because let's face it after season four
was never it's never as good as seasons
one through four personal opinion just
say if you look at it in its execution
it feels like a season a Game of Thrones
you got someone who's captive a Council
of people or vampires in this case
they're all scheming like okay what's
our battle plan and you don't actually
see the battle happen you just hear
about the planning maybe they'll be on a
quest i the last three seasons you might
not get that season finale fulfillment
in between so I really feels like they
might be trying to fill that void Brenda
they don't have george RR martin writing
the lord they don't have the dialogue
that sticks with you more than the
action sequences it's like battle of the
bastards it was fine that monologue
Petyr Baelish gave about how chaos isn't
debate chaos is a ladder way cooler
gossiping he has like charming endearing
cheesy dialogue which I do give him
credit for the fight any of the fights
in the show in this season season three
they were all learned they were just I'm
making it rain like we gotta have a
fight this episode because you know
vampires and humans and magic that's
what you do know what's going down a
fight was happening you're like okay
it's it's led to this last three
episodes in particular last three
episodes of this season locked in I'm
really in the end that's my take of
castlevania season 3 season 3 really
restructures and resets up the world in
a way where it's like I I don't know
who's gonna die next season if anyone
will is Isaac gonna succeed or is he
gonna die I don't know
is Hector gonna die I don't know I just
I don't know where it's gonna go
me [ __ ] Trevor Belmont could die next
season I don't know it's a rare feeling
for a show to give me and I feel like
Castlevania is giving me that because of
season 3 so props for that the animation
still glorious at first I was like oh I
like the new characters more than I like
Trevor Belma Alec cards kind of mopey
but really they're all learning their
lessons in this season that they're
gonna take with them gonna take it with
them forever it's gonna change them if
someone told me by the way a couple of
side characters that are introduced in
season 2 you're going to be most
invested with them over Alucard over
Trevor Belmont I would have been
impossible at first this season felt
like DLC where it's like well yeah
Dracula gets called back at the
beginning of every game but what
happened before that yes he gives a [ __ ]
when he comes back he's back and that's
what we care about this season did a
good job for the show at taking a leap
into something that could pay off and
give the show legs there's the best I
can phrase it seasons 1 & 2 are my
favorites
over 3 but if Castlevania does span a
few season 6 season 7 10 whatever and it
does become the long-form epic that this
season seems to set it up for we'll look
back at season 3 as the moment that that
started that it became that it went from
the simple crew taking on Dracula and
his minions to long-form character epic
in which most the characters weren't
even in season 1 they weren't even in
the show I actually signed on for
initially but I like that the characters
are standing on their own not writing
Dracula's coattails but again gotta
stick the landing shows don't always do
that but I really want to show you
season 4 leave the audience wanting more
and definitely I want more Castlevania
all right so Castlevania season 3 have
you seen it why did you think about it
did you like it as much as Castlevania
seasons 1 and 2 did you like it more
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more lonely
elder cards what it feels like when you
see that your friends are organising a
party on Facebook and you're just not in
the invite lonely Alucard is the kind of
person who would get a telephone
solicitor to block their number blown
Leal ooh card is the guy at the 20 year
high school reunion who's like yeah some
stuff going on you know it's good only
Alucard is the person who opens the door
couple of Mormon missionaries have rung
the doorbell and after talking their ear
off for three and a half hours and they
want to leave because they're bored is
like there's no wait come on in hey
lonely Alucard is a mood a very sad mood